hey everyone welcome to another episode
of unlocking lily so I believe that this
world would be a better place if we all
just embrace who we truly are
evan is currently an investor in my
business and is helping me grow my
coaching and speaking practice and it's
such an incredible honor to have you
guys join me on my startup journey I
made the decision to move to Thailand
with a guy and just so you know that
decision has raised a lot of questions
for a lot of people and one of those
questions were Lily you are a girl boss
how could you possibly risk everything
they have worked so hard towards for
some guy and honestly that thought never
crossed my mind at all and the reason
for that is I am NOT attached to labels
even if they're positive ones yeah I'm a
girl boss yeah I'm gonna build my
multi-million dollar business and I want
to follow my heart
and see what this is gonna take me I'm
not gonna allow what any label to rob me
from experiencing life to the fullest by
me following in my heart to Thailand
could potentially mean that I could get
my heart broken and it completely hit
the fan and I come back saturated and
I'm okay with on but what I'm not okay
with is living my life with regret
wondering what would have happened if
and not the thing something that is so
national for me not to be attached to
labels is not natural to a lot of people
and I do get that I coach a lot of men
and a lot of them are tied to the label
of being a man and in their head a man
is someone who doesn't show his feelings
who doesn't show his vulnerability who
doesn't ask for help
because they're so attached to the label
of being a man they feel like they need
to man them all the time which sucks
because it hurts them so much it hurts
them in their relationship and hurts
them in their business and it isolates
them because they feel like they can't
share in business when things are going
they are afraid to ask for help because
it's not the manly thing to do they
suffer in silence in their cars
frustrated hoping that someone would
help them but they are so afraid to ask
for help because it's going to hurt them
and threaten their manliness when they
go home to their wives when they're
asked at the dinner table how to date
and they say it's fire when it's not
they afraid to show their emotions to
the people that are closest to them
because they are afraid that they'd not
come across as a man it drifts people
apart relationships break up because men
cannot share her with their lives and
women we want to know what is going on
with you we want to be there for you we
want you to have those emotions we want
to see you feel things but they are so
afraid to show that because it's not the
manly thing to do instead they isolate
themselves in pain and suffering and
that causes so many issues not only does
it cause health issues that causes
psychological issues and to go really
extreme some men have committed suicide
because they feel like they cannot show
their true self and all of this in the
sake of keeping to a particular level of
being a man now I have the wonderful
opportunity to work with these men and
I'm able to slowly peel them back a
little bit so they could be more
vulnerable and show their feelings and
set themselves free from this label of
being a man but not everybody has that
and you don't have to be a man to be to
be bound to a label either so what I
really want to do is I want to share
with you one thing that I did for myself
that really helped me shed that label or
any label for that matter those placed
on me and that stems from one place that
is the unconditional love from yourself
now this unconditional love thing seems
so foreign when it comes to her
we can love other people unconditionally
we could love our animals
unconditionally but we have such a huge
problem loving ourselves unconditionally
so we need to put an end to that and I'm
going to share with you two things to do
to help with that the first thing is
self-acceptance like GPCR says we are
all a bunch of naked weirdos under a
clothes and now the thing we are weird
there are so many quarks about us that
is a little bit embarrassing and funny
but makes us who we are and we need to
accept ourselves for that because it
doesn't matter what people think of us
so whatever labels that they place on us
if we fully accept who we are so if you
have a pen and paper there I want you to
write down I accept myself for blank and
make it really weird like what is that
about you guys just downright
embarrassing me you're embarrassed to
even admit in public so although I
accept myself for being horribly clumsy
I fall all the time I twist my ankle
moment standing and it doesn't seem like
much for a lot of people but I'm also a
trained dancer so for a dancer to be
clumsy and uncoordinated is almost
unheard of
but I love that about myself I think
it's so funny that I'm clumsy so for you
what are those things and make it
positive like even though it's
embarrassing and weird and quirky but
that's what makes you who you are so it
needs to start with self-acceptance
first the second thing is to daily
practice you need to practice loving
yourself every single day of your life
the same way as you would love anybody
else whether it's a romantic partner
your child or friend you don't just
don't say to someone I love you once and
for the next 45 50 years you just assume
that love is being shown by you saying
it once right it's a daily practice you
have to treat yourself as someone you
really love
so every single day I'm gonna pull out
your job and you're gonna write down I
love myself for blank I love myself or
blank three times over every single day
and I know at the beginning it's gonna
feel so weird you're like I can't
believe I'm doing this
it's kind of weird and funny but
eventually when you do it you're gonna
notice that your self-love is gonna
continue to grow and grow and grow and
grow and it's gonna become automatic it
has helped me significantly in my life
and it's gonna help you too the reason
why it's so important to start from
unconditional love for yourself is
because too many people attach the
self-worth to a particular label whether
if it's girlboss whether if it's being a
man or something else when you feel like
there's certain things are threatening
that particularly your self-worth goes
down in actuality you're so much bigger
than your labels you are infinite
there's so many things you're capable of
doing that you don't even know yet so to
play small and tie yourself to a
particular label is not healthy alcohol
when you have unconditional love for
yourself you give yourself the
permission to live fully as your true
self and of a special shout out for
halona black hello no thank you so much
for writing that comment in my last
video his support means a lot to me and
the question of the day is what is that
one label that you really want to let go
of right now leave in the comments below
and I'll join in on the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching and more
importantly being on this journey with
me as I grow and change and move it
gives me so much comfort and knowing
thank you guys are there for me every
step of the way so thank you so much
again and I'll see you
very very soon what if you tell yourself
a story long enough you start to believe
it won't you believe it you act like it
I am Tulsa what a wail out of handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for two
hundred fifty four days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and five minutes long that you start
your morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access